so my talk is about a parameter in a
possible ability so most of the the
harmless result of approximation only
lose out a polynomial time algorithm so
in this talk I want to show that eth can
be used to to reveal the existence of
exponential time approximation algorithm
and our starting point is the
maximum K subset intersection problem so
we are given a collection of subset of a
finite set of n elements and the goal of
this problem is to select
from this collection and with the
maximum size of intersection
and another formulation of this problem
is to given a bipartite graph
a in a union B and we want to find a k
vertex set
of a with maximum number of common
Neighbors
so
we we're trying to try to find a maximum
uh by by part by click
with a fixed number
in in its left side Okay so
so this problem is MP heart and uh and
we can solve it in
but in N to the power of K by uh both
Force searching
so the question is can we do better than
this blue first searching in particular
can we find an fpt approximation
algorithm
with a ratio R by an fpd algorithm I
mean the algorithms the learning half
this argument is f of K times polynomial
of N and uh
approximation means that it retains a a
solution whose size is one over R times
the optimal one
so in the literature of uh approximation
algorithm we always consider polynomial
uh
time algorithm so if we restrict to
polynomial time of course Dimension
algorithm then the answer to this
question is
since no under some hardness of
assumption
so it is not difficult to see that uh
if we have a personal algorithm for the
maximum case subset in the session then
we can use this approximation algorithm
to solve the mass by click problem or
mass x by clicking by running by going
through all the possible value of K
so hope this result are based on the PCP
sharing and it produce a
an instant an optimal instance of with a
large number of K
so it does not rule out approximation
algorithm in fpt time
so
so why is it so difficult to so in
parameter in person Mobility result
and
because the religion is most of the
proof In classical impossible ability
relies on the PCP CRM and reduction
based on the participation always
produce instance with an optimal
solution of last site for example the
parameter K in in this in this instance
may be a polynomial of N and in
parameter capacity we all we assume that
K is us is very small it should not
depends on n
so
the memory is out of this talk is to
give a fpt get producing reduction from
K click to the maximal K subset
intercession problem in particular given
on input and vertex graph G and a small
integer K we we can construct a
bipartite graph H in polynomial time
such that if G contains a k click then
there are s vertex in
in the left side of this paper diagram
with a last last number of common
neighbors and otherwise
every s vertex in of a
aesthetic set of a has very small number
of common neighbors and we know that the
there is a huge gap between these two
terms
and here s is the
the is equal to K just 2 is the X number
of a k click
so this our reduction does not use the
PCB serum and in fact it it is based on
some is Gmail combinatorial Construction
so it
if the price in a case with small value
of K
so let's see what we can get from this
yeah
so
uh
an immediate consequence is to to use
use the
n to the power of K lower bound of the K
click problem and the eth
and the code that we our reduction is
from kclick to maximum case of
intercession and we increase the
parameter from K to K2 so we have a n to
the square root of K lower bound
uh for the
for for approximation algorithm of this
problem with ratio with resource ratio
and
we can by duplicating the vertex in the
pythonograph h
uh but Delta times for some fixed Delta
for some physical Delta we can
obtain a variant of our main sharing
where the
s vertex
the the S vertex is replaced by S
multiplied by Delta and then we can
get a
in a possibility result of Maximum case
of intersection with a trade-off between
the approximation ratio and it's running
time
so it seems that if we want to rule out
a larger approximation relation we have
to sacrifice the the lower bound of this
runtime
and of course this okay foreign
yes
yes only these problems
so there's no reason to reject the the
Delta to be a constant and we for
example we can set Delta to be
2K 2 to the power of K Over s and then
we
we can we have a gap reduction from Okay
click to
to
2 to the power of K
such intercession right and
then we can obtain the corresponding
lower bound with N2
power block K and to the ratio the local
rules of n
now we have seen a gap producing
reduction and some simple consequence of
it under eth
so
um natural follow-up question is what
can we do with this Gap so
so we
can we find can we divide the inner
personability Reserve of other natural
parameter problems
based on this Gap
in particular we want to find some Gap
preserving fpt reduction from
the case of the intercession to click or
to okay dominating set
so first let's let us try uh take click
we want to find an fpt algorithm a
and such that
um
H you construct a graph G
satisfying if
if they are s vertex
in a with large common neighbor then G
has a
click of G of K vertex
And if every
s vertex in H has small number of common
neighbors then
G contains the most G of K over two
click so we want to know if if there is
such a
get preserving reduction
and
a naive idea is
so here we have by paragraph H we use
the color color coding technique to
get
to color the vertex set a
with s color
and we call the vertex type B with say
two times K plus 1 factorial different
color then we add edge
between vertex in a with different color
and and we do the same thing for
for the vertex in b
so it seems that after we add this Edge
after we
call this vertex and add the edge
between different vertices
between vertex with different color then
in the case case one
we have
we have a s vertex side with large
common number of uh with large number of
common neighbor so we have a S Plus
to we we have a click whose size is
close to 2 times K plus one factorial we
assume that also s is equal to K2 so the
size is done dominated by this time
and in the second case it seems that
h
a lot lots that is Click of H is close
to K plus 1 factorial right
um
okay so
so this argument is not correct because
they may
because they may exist and in the second
case then
every s vertex has more common neighbor
but then exit s minus one vertex in a
with a large number of combinator this
leads to a
click whose size is close to the case
one so
we still don't know how to
find a gap reserving reduction from from
subset intersection to click
so next we let's try a dominating set so
let gamma G be the size of the
minimal dominating set of the graph G
so
we can ask a similar question can we
find an fpt algorithm that only put a
rather graph you can graph G if if H has
s vertex with large common neighbor then
the dominant set of G is is smaller than
G of K for some computable function G
and if every s vertex of a has a small
number of common neighbors then
set of G is larger than 2 of 2 times G
of K
so in this case we we succeed and
basically eja and I has so that Basin
and
an fpt algorithm that
of
from Maximum case of the intercession to
the dominating set that achieve a
constant ratio for for the dominating
set problem
and
so in particular we
are we construct a graph
which is
is a pro C product of a
of the
photo diagram H and and for every if if
if there exists s vertex with B common
number then the minimum dominating set
of G is less than one plus Epsilon times
D to the power of C for some constant C
And if every s vertex of a has a small
number of common neighbors then the
dominant side of G is larger than C
c times D to the power C over three and
these are very huge
so and
immediately
quality of this reduction is we can root
out a constant apt approximation
algorithm for dominating set for
under fpt not equal to W1 and
and assuming eth we can improve the
the
hardness ratio
from constant to a
super slightly super constant which is
close to the first root of log of the
size of the dominant instead of G
the with uh
under any environment right the running
time is
by the size of dominating set of G
that's the current F of the problem
gamma G is the parameter and so
technology is the size of determininity
set and so it is the parameter
so let us fail to mention the uh
polynomial time
in English in personability of
dominating set so so we know that it the
hardening installation of foreign
and as far as the parameterized settings
can send not much is no and for for
independent dominance side we know that
it has no
fpt approximation algorithm to any
computer both ratio function and the fpt
not equals W2 however the independent
dominance set is is not monotone which
means that if if s is a independent
dominated set it's
superset may not be a
independent domain intercept
so it we don't know how to find get
preserving reduction from independent
dominators to dominating set
so in the
in the last part of
paper
on that one the hardness of exactly the
same problem and we have also another
archive breaker on that
no I it did it so you I I I to remember
you have some result about
communication and click but
everything in
personability without coming inside and
click but you based on some non-standard
hypothesis
like a project game conjecture
okay
all right okay
getting super explanation time you
cannot get a better deal
look to the worthless Epsilon for
example
for dominance has this Gap producing
syndrome that was essentially in another
paper that they have in two years in
archives but but do you look up all the
fpt algorithms for the termination yeah
I mean are there some running time
essentially
but
the learning time of the algorithm
depends on the ratio you
of the problem
all right
so I I need to check the paper later
foreign
is based on PCP
oh
so in the in the
last session I want to show you the the
main idea of our Gap producing reduction
so let us use the gamma X to denote the
set of common neighbors of all the
vertex in
X and
our goal is to to given a an advantage
of G and we want to construct a
pipelagraph h in apt such that if G
contains Okay click then we can exit an
S vertex set
with large number of
common neighbor where H is can be used
to the cases and otherwise
the common neighbor of every s vertex
setup is very small
so
so that
the key idea is to construct a bipartite
graph
key whose left side is the vertex set of
G
and it's satisfied two nice property
first every K plus one vertex
with a set of V VG has a small number of
common neighbors and second
for for random truth cable desk set of V
of G with high probability it has a
large number
common neighbors so like like this
picture shows
the parameter K is equal to 3 so a K
plus 1 vertex set has a small number
of common neighbors well for for this
three vertex set that has most of them
has a large number of common neighbor
and
so the next step is to add the edge of G
to
to the left side of this
by paragraph t
so if G contains a k click then with
high probability we
the this K vertex has a large number of
common Neighbors in in this graph
and then we construct a
graph h
whose left side vertex
set is
the The Edge set of G
so if if we have a click with with this
number of neighbors then we
then it's Edge set here
has this large number column number and
the The Edge number of Okay click is
equal to s
so on so in this direction we are done
so
suppose that g does not convince a k
click
then every s h from The Edge set of G
must must use at least
K plus 1 vertex
so like this case
and three vertex as a three Edge must
use four vertex and
we must use K plus one vertex and in in
the
in this
mathematic gravity K plus one vertex set
has small number of common labels
so
it doesn't it'll be best to solve how to
construct the paragraph T so in this
slides I want to give you the
integration of the probability
construction of t
so given up so we can start by a random
graph and with every
two vertex is joined by an edge with
probability p
and
the expect number of the common
neighbors of a s of a K plus 1 vertex
subset is
about is is
one and
and the expect number of of common num
common neighbors of a k vertex subset of
a is
he's here let's be larger than
of K plus one what I said
so
so I want to mention that uh with our
reduction can can be uh
to randomize so to to the end we need to
define the bypatography in more
sophisticated way so by by partition the
the left side of the
photograph T into uh and Destroy Union
of subset
and we keep the property T1 and change
and replace the probability to with
this
so
we we want to for
the for those K vertex okay vertex set
with large common neighbors we want to
we want them to appear in a more
predictable way so that we can use it in
a in a reduction
and it is not difficult to to adapt our
reduction to to the parallelogram T 35
T1 and T2 Prime and the most technical
thing is to construct such graph
yeah they think deterministic
okay
in summary in we give an apt Gap
producing reduction for from kclick to
maximum case substance intercession and
we under 8th we can roll out some
moderate in this potential time
approximately some algorithm for for
this problem and we can even have a
trade-off between the the approximation
ratio and it's running time and then we
try to derive the in a possibility
result of other natural parameter
problem under this Gap and so far we can
can we can only rule out the constant
ability approximately for dominating set
so it remains to be seen that if KK
click has a constant ability of
approximation of the dominance that have
a fpt approachment with with some
computable
ratio function
do you use a fpt is different in the W1
uh we we can use fpts different from W1
so if we use this we
some because you got any time that you
want there
I mean the T was not a problem
did you use
spt is different phases
you mean to obtain the
happiness result for
for click or for anything maybe
so the first
I guess we use it and the point is use
fpt is different from W1 we can only
rule out constant in uh
you can use the Expression to prove the
deputy yeah it's not W1 yeah then you
get any time that you want for free
anytime for free
I'm down only a matter of blowing that
Gap
so I I couldn't get how to approach
maybe I think you you mean
yes we use it right yeah thank you very
much
what
dth implies W1 is
and also the value 2 is not effective it
is
log out
that is the paper that they are in 2013.
but you have got the cup on the time
that you yeah
there is
a result that you want
foreign
I'm from uh
showing that you cannot solve the
amazing
basically an fpt
so much yes
but here K has nothing to do with
anything because case reduce beforehand
a very very small function and it has
nothing to do with anything
so if there are no more questions